wie das eigentlich so vor wenn du dann
in der luft ist
nach dem sprung ein bisschen druck
hallo
das geht aber nur ein megabyte gefühl
von freiheit
also ich bin so froh nicht der mensch
für achterbahn und so ich hoffe mal dass
ich das überlebe ich habe ein bisschen
angst vor der landung weil ich habe
angst dass meine ganze funktioniert also
nennen
wir sind ja gleich mit acht mann also
was drin in diesem winzigen flugzeug
also darf schon krass wenn du dann oben
stehst über diese lücke und runter
schoss und beim springen
es ist ja auch so eine urangst und dann
3000 meter oder wie hoch das auch ist
keine ahnung das wird schon ziemlich
extrem
gleich gehts los
max
also mit am krassesten panik definitiv
raus zu springen erst mal weil das ging
so unglaublich schnell dann also ich im
moment gebraucht dann erstmal überhaupt
so richtig zu realisieren was abgeht so
denn die augen aufzumachen
also beides sehr cool aber ich würde
sogar noch zum rheinfall in dem auch
wenn du die ganze zeit einen ball
gefangen zu werden die wolken nicht so
eins weil die er im flugzeug aus dem
lokal drauf waren und dann als ihr
wirklich denn punkte gesprungen sind
weil es auch mega cool is gefühl wie
noch bei euch strand auf
nicht so so ging und das nächste mal bei
action haus
freddy wie im bereich der führer zu
verlieren